I'm kind of angry at some of my
listeners and stuff because um you know
I was thinking about the hundredth
episode and me calling people and not
picking up and you know it just really
enrages me
it enrages me and I might have to do
some calls today try again well you have
any different numbers George producer is
like I don't teach you that Columbia
yeah I hope so
hey do you have a budget for yeah I
learned how to make uh artsy European
films at Columbia that doesn't help me
at all right now
I actually thought you meant like
Columbia about the Ivy League's well you
went there you get mugged blacked out
from a drug and then ya get peed on how
did you like Utah Clara I didn't go oh
you didn't go I stayed here to watch the
fights with not you because you flaked
on me that's it it's all getting so what
is it will you caught your calling first
no I call put on speakerphone yeah I
call you don't call first give me the
[ __ ] phone I've already done that
before George six ibis what's the name
hang up or press one for more options
yo Frank yeah dawg
Frank was King old King bet you hear
what I'm saying
because television and [ __ ] bro busy
busy busy busy
the busy bee Frank
we're doing that throughout the show
we'll be doing that throughout the show
um where you getting these numbers they
submitted it once or submitted number
yeah we got a hot so we're gonna call
them no not eventually let's call all of
them right now $500 give me another
lover man give me another number I'm
into it
do we have a spa-like because we got a
spa competition right yeah we can call
them too yeah we'll come a little later
[Music]